اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بفخامه الشاقين
البجدارز رئيس دوله منغوليا السابق عضو
مجلس العلوم والامن في نشره علماء الذره
اهلا بك معنا فخامه الرئيس وفي البدايه لو
تشرح لنا مفهوم ساعه القيامه
كما ذكرتي بدات في عام 1947
واجتمعت
العقول العبقريه لبدي هذه الساعه ومنذ ذلك
الوقت فساعه يوم القيامه وحتى اليوم
عده 25 مره
وتسعه عشره مره
الى الامام ومرات اخرى الى الخلف والان
عده ساعه الى تسعين ثانيه فقبل منتصف
الليل
وعندما
[موسيقى]
الانسانيه واصحاب القرار بشكل خاص حول
الازمات النوويه
والازمات المرتبطه بالاسلحه النوويه ولكن
بعد ذلك في الحقيقه فان يوم القيامه
اخذت ابي نظري لاعتبار التهديدات الاخرى
الان
نقول ان هناك ثلاث تهديدات اساسيه مرتبطه
اولا الاسلحه النوويه والجائحه
والتهديد الاخر هو ازمه المناخ
والتهديد الرابع الناشئ ونسميه
التكنولوجيا الاحلاليه او التقنيات
التخريبيه وكل هذه جنبا الى جنب تجعل
عالمنا اكثر ضعفا كما ان الساعه يوم
القيامه واودون اذكر مساله هامه هي في
الحقيقه تحذر الانسانيه
من تلك
التهديدات التي سببها البشر ونسميها
تهديدات وجوديه وساعه يوم القيامه اخيرا
في عام 2020
عده الى مئه ثانيه وعشرين واحد وعشرين
قرروا ان لا يحركوها اما في 20 23
فالعلماء
وخبراء اخرون ممن درسوا المشاكل الامنيه
قرروا
باعدادها الى تسعين ثانيه قبل منتصف الليل